monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés la France rime avec puissance la
France c'est un repère c'est un idéal
c'est un patrimoine témoin d'une
histoire millénaire la France ce n'est
pas seulement le bonheur des paysages
une langue enrichie des œuvres de
l'esprit c'est d'abord une histoire une
histoire où s'est forgé le modèle
républicain oui elle est belle la France
cette MAJ oui elle est belle la France
la France est fière et audacieuse
cert nous sommes comme d'autres dans la
crise nous voyons bien que l'arc des
crises se développe les crises se
superposent sans chevêtre et
s'additionne et sans une croissance plus
forte nous ne ferons rien nous devons
retrouver une croissance durable qui dit
croissance dit libération des forces
vives du pays que le gouvernement est
disposé à écouter
à dialoguer à discuter que la justice
sociale est au centre de nos
préoccupations le gouvernement sera
toujours prêt au dialogue rien n'est
possible sans l'écoute et le dialogue
nous avons mesdames et messieurs les
députés renforcer le dialogue social
dans l'entreprise parce qu'on ne bâtit
pas une économie efficace sur les
décombres de la cohésion sociale le
gouvernement quant à lui attache la plus
haute importance à l'intensification du
dialogue social une nation moderne ne
peut vivre et se développer sans un
dialogue social nourri mais je vous le
dis je ne renoncerai jamais à dialoguer
ma porte sera toujours ouverte le
gouvernement a dit et il le prouve qu'il
est bien celui de la concertation et du
progrès nous avons encore des droits à
conquérir des progrès à réaliser des
protections à bâtir cette idée du
progrès rassemble les Français parce que
le progrès déjoue les scénarios écrits à
l'avance parce que le progrès
compromis être français en 2024 c'est
vivre dans un pays qui n'a pas renoncé
au progrès social partout nous
constatons les dérèglements climatiques
la pollution de l'air des sols et des m
nous gagnerons la bataille du climat il
y a aussi la nécessité écologique il
s'agit là d'un enjeu planétaire majeur
auquel nous répondr le dérglement
climatique nous frappe plus dur plus
fort
plusent au français c'est avec une
ambition claire dire la vérité je dirais
donc la vérité au français je veux dire
aux françaises et aux Français la vérité
je vous dois la vérité parce qu'elle est
au cœur de la rupture nous sommes un
peuple adulte mûri par les épreuves
désireux d'entendre de comprendre le
langage de la vérité je tiendrai le
discours de la vérité ma méthode est
claire elle reste la même dire les
choses dire la vérité même quand ça fait
mal nous avons besoin de votre confiance
active mesdames et messieurs comme nous
avons besoin de la confiance et du
concours de tous les Français je
chercherai non par la
démagogie mais par l'action à restaurer
la confiance nos concitoyens ont besoin
de retrouver confiance dans la vie
politique et en particulier en ceux qui
l'animent que l'on contribue à restaurer
cette valeur cardinale qui soude les
sociétés comme les valeurs humaines la
confiance et l'essentiel c'est de
redonner confiance aux Français dans
leur
avenir